french documentary the monopoly of
violence
exposes and examines police brutality in
france
focusing on recent yellow vest protests
but also taking in the suburbs
a harrowing watch it uses footage shot
by journalists
or members of the public
showing clips like this though may not
be possible in the future
the french government has proposed a new
security law
part of which would crack down on the
broadcast or sharing of
images of police officers filmmaker
david dufrene
says the bill destroys basic freedoms
the lawmakers want to stop the free
circulation of information and knowledge
because in the last few years france has
discovered police violence
it's something that in reality has
existed for a very long time in the
suburbs but was not documented in this
way
video has been used in several
high-profile cases of alleged police
violence in the country
the death of delivery man cedric
schuviad during a police check in paris
in january
was filmed by a passer-by footage that
led to an inquiry
in parliament mps debated the bill if
passed a person could be jailed for up
to a year and
find more than fifty thousand dollars
for broadcasting or sharing
identifiable images of a police officer
with the intention of harming them
outside journalists and opponents the
law gathered to protest
campaigners fear that if journalists and
citizens are dissuaded from filming the
police it will make it
harder to hold some officers accountable
for their actions
and some may act with impunity but the
government says the law is necessary
to protect the safety of police officers
it's not about stopping journalists from
working the law doesn't impact the right
to inform for journalists or citizens
but it prevents police officers from
having their identities put online
with cause to violence or to be subject
to reprisals that can have grave
consequences
protecting the police from violence
while on duty is essential says this
police union spokesperson
but he says the new law is not the
answer
what they can and cannot do then this
clause would not be necessary
unrested demonstrations and recent
attacks have prompted the government to
take a tougher line
on security but instead of working on
building more trust between police
officers and the public
some say the new law threatens to erode
it
natasha butler al jazeera paris